what's made here in Newport reaches
every corner of our lives but Britain's
largest microchip Factory's future is
now uncertain after the UK government
ordered its Chinese owners to sell up
due to National Security
this sends a message of the world that
the UK is not open for business but it's
close for business this is not leveling
up this is leveling down for the people
here in uh in in Wales do you find them
in televisions watches washing machines
last year Newport wafer Fab was taken
over by nextperia this summer that deal
was reviewed now overruled with Linda's
job and more than 500 others at risk
absolutely devastated
um
wasn't expected at all there are a lot
of young people here that have just got
mortgages they've got children Chinese
UK relations have changed dramatically
since David Cameron had a pint with
President Xi Jinping in a pub now more
suspicious than ever
the UK government's become concerned
that by allowing a chinese-owned company
to take over this Factory they're
effectively selling off a prized asset
overseas at a time when there's a global
shortage of what they make here silicon
chips a mix of National Security worries
and economic ones too because this is
the tech our future is made of
the decision to force out China likely
influenced by politicians fearing the
consequences of the country's access to
technology Here China poses a systemic
threat to us and the one thing that they
are desperate to get hold of is the
technology around microprocessors on
which everything else relies so if we
allow them to do that and catch up with
the wrestlers in the west then there's
no telling the damage that they could do
nextperia will appeal to a lay National
Security fears but with repercussions
stretching far beyond Wales there could
be a fierce battle ahead
Adele Robinson Sky News Newport